[Music]
yeah penile pain and action that's nice
it's basically it's a battery
transmitter to monitor rigging and then
we have a transmitter on the other
camera a cool new piece of technology
for indie filmmakers recommend we'll see
all right so he'll be in the foreground
here the idea is that I'm gonna come up
up and over the hill behind them take my
pistol up and when that happens you need
to give him a cue so you can look back
and go oh [ __ ] and get dive out of the
way as I start shooting okay and then
I'm gonna run through the frame
basically I'm gonna Rob to basically his
position and across here because he is
[Music]
cool shoulder sword three two one action
yeah I got this
got the fight still happens just
generally along this line and I come in
Nikko let's hear so you're fighting like
this at this line I come in like this
thank you one accent and literally on
action I chuck the water okay here we go
ready action funny shot we shot the day
[Music]
yeah light him three two one wait wait
three two one remarkably close to me to
do pick at any air
you